This program is being presented to you
by the Heraeus International Winter
School on gravity and light.
Welcome to the 14th lecture. This will
be a rather brief lecture and it's on
matter. Now on matter one should rather
give a four or five lecture than one
and we can impossibly do the subject any
justice but we'll do what we will need
in order to continue with what we're
actually interested in mainly in the
school.
And so essentially there are two types
of matter.
Um
that's not physical types, they're more
like theoretical types of matter
and one type we call point matter.
And the other one is field matter.
And you know examples of both so here
you have
a massive point particle and here for
instance you have the electromagnetic
field.
Now what's the status of these two? Well
in the real world none of the two exists
because those are both classical matter
types and we will only look at classical
matter in these lectures. That's the
first thing.
The second thing is actually from the
point of view of general relativity
field matter is the fundamental type of
matter whereas point matter plays a big
role in the phenomenon phenomenology of
general relativity. For instance we
already discussed what massive and
massless point particles and so on do
so they play a role but in principle for
instance the massless ones you could
discuss them like you discussed the
geometric optical limit of
electromagnetic theory you do
geometrical optics and then you talk
about light rays and so on even in
classical electrodynamics is a geometric
optical limit gives rise to then
maybe an action for for for light
particles although
in the fundamental field theory there's
no such thing. So in a sense the field
matter is more fundamental from the
point of view of general relativity.
For more fundamental from
the GR point
of view.
For instance
it will be field matter that generates
the curvature of space-time. So if we
say matter curves space-time we'll take
field matter.
Now you can always take point matter and
make it into fake field matter.
Okay
there will be problems in the tutorials
about that.
So this is more like an academic
distinction sometimes it's easier to
express physical ideas here sometimes
it's easier to write down equations here
but really this is not like we're we're
claiming that two different types of
matter in the in nature like these two
but it's more like emphasis is more on
the field matter.
Okay and so this is more
of a pheno
menological
importance.
So if I wanted to be very pure one would
only talk about field matter and derive
from there statements about the
geometric optical limit however that
seems overly
academic.
So we'll start with point matter.
And as I said this can only be
a course overview of
what one can say about matter. So our
postulates P1 and P2
Remember that was that a massive
particles always runs such that at every
local light cone the tension vector lies
within the cone and massless particles
run such that every point the tension
vector lies on the boundary of the light
cone at the point. Our postulates P1 and
P2 already constrain
constrain the possible
particle world lines.
However the question is okay
how does a particular particle really
move? And that's the same question you
have in classical mechanics what's
actually the law of motion.
Okay and
but what is the law of motion?
What is
their precise
law
of motion
possibly
in the presence
of forces.
Now
you know that in Newtonian mechanics you
have this idea of say the gravitational
force other forces that act at a
distance right? So somewhere there's the
origin of the force the the the source
of the force and you have a particle
here and it reacts to it just like that.
Now in relativity of course it doesn't
make any sense anymore.
And the picture becomes much more of
that that there is a particle source
somewhere and that source sources a
field for instance an electromagnetic
field. Very roughly speaking then the
electromagnetic field propagates
somewhere else and only then can another
particle coupling to the field feel it
there.
So really we replace forces
entirely by the field concept that
they're interaction fields. Okay?
And I'll give one example for that
and but the more basic question is what
is the precise law of motion without the
forces so let's start with A without
external forces.
Well and that's essentially
a postulate which however later on will
turn out to be not a postulate at all
but a consequence of the Einstein field
equations. So we have the action of a
massive particle world line
is simply
D lambda square root
G V gamma gamma of lambda
V gamma gamma of lambda.
And the G is taken at each of these
points.
So it's just the length of the world
line is the action and there is the mass
in front of it.
And you say it doesn't matter whether I
have the mass in front of it or not if I
write down the Euler-Lagrange equation
the mass will cancel out. Yes but later
on we will add interaction terms and
then the mass will be of relative
importance.
Okay so this is already all that is to
be said about this.
Um
you know that you can instead of having
the square root you could leave out the
square root and normalize the curve to
geometric parameter that you require
that this Lagrangian be one all the time
but we would certainly also require um
with the condition that G gamma of
lambda of T gamma of lambda comma V
gamma gamma of lambda that this be
greater than zero.
So
we certainly want
curves
to run
such in this direction and not in this
direction. This direction the tangent
vector would not lie in the cone. That's
why we chose these half cones in the
first place. So you want a future
directed
a future directed world line that is a
stationary curve of this action. So
whenever I write down an action it's
implied that I get the field equations
as the Euler-Lagrange equations of this.
Right? So dynamical law
Euler-Lagrange equations
of S massive.
That's just it we postulate this.
Similarly
we have S massless
gamma
equals now there are various ways to do
this we just do it in this way V gamma
lambda
V gamma gamma of lambda is just without
the square root and a slick way to do it
is to introduce an additional Lagrange
multiplier here that's another function
mu of lambda and so you have to vary
this action with respect to the gamma
and with respect to the mu.
And if you vary with respect to mu the
corresponding Euler-Lagrange equations
just force you to have
a null curve. Well that's how you call
that
in the jargon. You have a curve whose
tangent always lies on the boundary of
the cone. Okay? And the variation with
respect to gamma that's the equation
equations of motion for these massless
particles.
Now
why do we insist well we don't really
insist but a little it's it's convenient
to start from an action
and to derive the equations of motion
rather than writing down the equations
of motion in the first place?
And the biggest advantage of this is
um that we can add actions. So, if you
have a complicated system, you can add
the actions.
Yes.
But you forgot the square root. No, I
didn't.
I didn't.
So, the point is
first of all, these curves cannot be
parameterized by their time
because time doesn't run along them,
roughly speaking, although that's a
meaningless statement because time we
only define for observers.
Observers always had time la- Oh, I
almost said it, time-like curves. Okay,
only always had curves whose tangents
are inside the cone.
Okay? Uh we didn't define time for these
null curves.
And um
this is the reason why it it wouldn't
serve us well, right? It's meaningless.
And indeed in this action uh there is no
square root.
Okay? Good. So, um
reason
for describing
matter
or equations of motion
by actions
is that
composite systems
um
have an action
that is the sum
of the actions
of the
parts of that system,
possibly including interaction terms,
possibly including
interaction
terms.
What's an interaction term?
Example.
Say you have an action
for one particle
and you have an action for another
particle. They have nothing to do with
each other.
But now you want to describe how they
interact,
then you need a part of need an
interaction part that contains both of
them
in terms that are product or something
such if you do the variation of the
total action,
the equations for gamma get a
contribution from there and the
equations from delta get a contribution
from there, too.
And this way you get an interaction
term.
And of course, the interaction terms are
modeled such that what comes out is what
you desire.
It's just a convenient It's just a
convenient tool.
Now,
we can look at
the presence of external forces,
external forces,
or rather, and that's the point of view
I advocated a minute ago, or rather,
presence
of fields
to which
a particle couples.
And that's again language,
jargon.
Um it means there is an interaction term
with the field. You had interaction
between two particles, but I can have an
interaction with a field. Actually,
we'll never look at something like this.
It's just to illustrate the concept. And
um
the prime example
is the following. You take a massive
point particle
d lambda
um m
square root
All of this is as it used to be.
V gamma gamma of lambda
And now you add a term, an interaction
term with an external field.
So, the field is assumed given. That's
why it's an external called an external
field. And say the field is a covector
field A.
So, not finished there yet.
Where A is a covector
field. So, a zero one tensor
on space time. Um
e.g.
the electro-
magnetic
potential.
Right?
E.g. the electromagnetic potential. If
it's a covector, what can it eat?
A vector.
What vector do I have? I have this
vector.
That's all it can do.
And um
you might only look at particles with a
certain charge Q.
If Q is zero, you don't feel the field.
It may be there, but you don't feel it.
The linearity of action composition of
system is an implicit assumption.
That you that you can add these?
No, it actually
There's actually no secret to it because
um
you have one big generating functional.
If they have different
uh curves, objects they depend on, of
course, variation with respect to this
will not see this. Variation with
respect to that will not see that. So,
you can add them without harm and not
lose information. Otherwise, you would
say, "I need that action and that
action." But you can add them without
harm. So, first of all, it's it's uh
you may add them and and you're not hit
over the head with it. But then um the
idea is if you then write a plus and
then you can do the interaction term.
Now, you say, "Oh, how do you know that
you can add the interaction term, too?"
The answer is because you will design
the interaction term such that it
produces precisely what you want.
So, the the mystery about the action is
a little bit too much, right? There is
nothing deep in in an action really, I
is my claim. Um
of course, you can talk about then in
quantum mechanics, the whole action
counts, not only the the stationary
points, and there's something there and
so on. But from a classical point of
view, it's just a convenient device.
Okay?
So, you have this
action
um and um now the question is with
respect to what do I vary this? Well,
the point is this is still an action for
the particle trajectory gamma, for a
massive particle trajectory gamma. And
um well, we may somehow also write the A
mu Sorry, the A in here, the covector
field, but maybe after a semicolon
because this one is considered fixed. I
assume it's already given
on my space time, okay? I'm now at the
moment not looking at how this is
evolving or where this comes from.
Um and so, it's not the action doesn't
really depend on it in that sense. It's
not supposed to be varied with respect
to the A.
Now, let's see what this is and why we
would couple it that way. Um so, um um
um
consider the Euler-Lagrange equations of
this.
Euler-Lagrange
equations
Well, now we know that from this part,
we already know what the Euler-Lagrange
equations are if I choose the right
parametrization, we know from this part
the Euler-Lagrange equations
are this. Do you agree?
And if this was all,
then the Euler-Lagrange equations would
be this if the Q was zero.
That's what we did before. Then it's
just a geodesic.
Now, we have this additional part, so we
have to
include
So, we could call this an interaction
already. So, we have to include the
Euler-Lagrange equations of this, so
they're being added. Plus So, how does
this go? Well, well, uh dL by d gamma
dot, so I go to a chart, what not,
m d by dxm
minus dL by d gamma m in that chart, in
that chart. And that's of course just
the L interaction, L interaction. Here
it's the L interaction with that field.
So, it's L interaction of the gamma
of the gamma, the gamma dot, and there's
the A in it, but the A
is just given, okay?
So, what are these additional terms? So,
if I
It's kind of interesting to look at
that. dL by d gamma dot m. What's the L?
L int equals in the chart, it's Q
A in the chart x uh m gamma in the chart
m dot. Agree?
That Yes. Sorry, uh the second the first
derivative with the first part of the
Euler-Lagrange. The d after d and Ah,
it's nonsense. Yeah, yeah. It's
nonsense.
Yes, thank you. Yeah, no, no, sorry,
sorry.
I was already in the field theory, but
even that that was just unsaveably
wrong. Thank you.
Okay.
So, you you do this derivative, and what
do you get? That's very simple. So,
let's go with respect to A. So, we can
also say here we get the A. It's
actually cleverer to to have the A still
down. If you do this derivation, you end
up with the A down because with the
metric you pulled it down, if you want.
Okay? Yeah, I said you shouldn't do
that. I know. I know.
It's good advice nevertheless.
Um
So, this is Q times A
X the A's component. Now, hang on. Yes,
it's true. And then I have to calculate
DL by D gamma M No, A
dot
dot. So, I have to take the dot of this.
What is this? This is Q. This is just a
constant. Now, I have to derive this.
This of course depends on the position
along the world line. So, I have D by DX
M
Um on the A
XA component times along the world line
gamma dot M.
Okay? That's the time derivative.
And finally, I need the DL by D gamma A
equals Well, the A depends on that as
we've just saw. This is Q times uh D by
D
um X
A
Um Yes, D by DX
X M gamma dot M.
gamma M dot
Right?
That's what this is.
Now, if you take this minus this, so you
take this guy here
as the star
then it follows that star equals This is
Q times
I take the gamma dot M out
dot X
and by miracle, you get D
A
D
Yeah, D A A in the X system by DXM
minus DAM
by DXA.
But we know this gentleman. This is Q
times
F
down A down M
gamma dot M
all in the X system.
And this is the Faraday tensor.
So, what we get in total here
we get M nabla V gamma V gamma
can pull up the index if you want equals
I take this to the other side, so I
change sign.
It's minus Q.
I pulled up the A index. I get F A M
gamma M dot.
Pardon me?
Here?
Thank you.
Thank you. And I calculated the right
ones.
And this right hand side is the E and
the B in there.
There's the velocity in there.
This is the Lorentz force law.
Lorentz force
on a charged particle
in an electromagnetic field.
So, the coupling
that was just wiped out. It's all right.
Um the coupling to the A field produces
exactly what we want, the Lorentz force
law. That is why this is the right
coupling.
Apart from the fact that it also
satisfies the nice property
that this guy here is reparameterization
invariant.
And this guy here is as well.
Because
reparameterization here will cancel
precisely
against the change of measure here.
So, this whole thing is still
reparameterization invariant.
Okay.
So, this is how you So, if you now want
to understand why this is really the
Lorentz force law, you need to ask an
observer. You need to extract the zero
and the alpha components with respect to
a particular observer.
And you will have to resolve the
summation convention with respect to a
frame of a particular observer. And then
you see the Lorentz force law.
None.
So, this is all in the
So, the right hand side here Well, this
here too because this is the component
in a system is all in the X system.
But you could of course easily write
this whole thing um
uh coordinate free. So, M
V gamma V gamma equals minus Q
um then you take the F
you have an open slot
you apply it to the V gamma.
Now, the open slot can eat another
vector. But that makes the whole thing a
covector.
Right?
A covector field.
And then you can lift the index by using
the sharp inverse.
There you go.
That's chart independent. Yes.
I start with the index down because if
you really do the variation, you will
arrive at um
You will actually arrive at this.
And only after you then
um
after you calculated this, you then do
an overall multiplication of this on
both sides with uh G
A C
in order to get the equation with an
index up C.
Yes, that's just the definition of that.
Yes.
We did this calculation and then we had
to pull up the metric here.
Okay?
Good.
This is all not difficult. It's just to
show how you deal with matter coupled to
forces and so on and so on.
Okay.
So, um more interesting is second field
matter.
Now
it's very difficult to give a definition
of matter that's not overstating or
understating what matter is. Because in
fact, we know there currently we believe
there four types of matter in the
standard model, right? Uh well, of
interaction matter and then there
uh uh a few Dirac fields around and so
on. And um but here we're talking about
classical field theory and um so, the
the definition is classical
field matter.
And once I'm there, I could actually say
it's just Maxwell theory.
Because really the only classical field
theory we have out there in nature
is Maxwell theory.
What else?
Okay? So, therefore as I said, it's very
difficult to give an abstract definition
that's not understating or under
overstating what matter is. But
nevertheless, we in general relativity
we're prepared to consider classical
field matter
is
any
uh tensor field
on space-time
um whose
um
equations of motion
derive
from
an action.
Okay, I mean this is really a very so
silly definition. It's just if I talk
about matter field matter, I mean
something like that. So, example
is as I said, S Maxwell.
Now, here Now, this is not a curve. This
is now a whole tensor field.
And in the case of Maxwell theory, it's
a 0 1 tensor field.
So, what's an action here? Well, then
the action must be something like an
integral over all of space-time.
Um
And now I'm
pretending for simplicity
that there is one chart
for simplicity, one chart
covers
all of M.
Okay?
If not, you have to do your partition of
unity and da da da, we're not going to
write this down. So, you have an
integral. You know you're on space-time,
you can write the determinant of G. But
because the G has signature plus minus
minus minus, the determinant will always
be negative. You want to take the square
root, you have to put a minus sign in
front of it. That's the only adaptation
you need to make compared to the
Riemannian integration we did, right?
So, this is just in order to compensate
for Lorentz signature.
Due
to plus minus minus minus signature,
okay?
And uh well, then for Maxwell, you have
the FAB
appears twice, FABFCD,
and the indices are related by AC
GBD.
And then you can have a 1/4 in front or
what, okay?
And that's the famous F mu nu F mu nu
action. Who of you has seen that?
Right. Now, that's just a relativistic
formulation. Now, because of this extra
factor, it works on curved space-time.
You probably saw it with eta eta.
The determinant of eta is minus one, so
this is one, so you don't see this, but
if you go to non-
Lorentzian coordinates, right? Uh you do
any other transformations than Lorentz
transformations, this term appears
nevertheless.
So, we need to introduce it. So, even in
flat space-time, it needs to be there if
you're in a chart that's not the
the trivial chart, okay? So, this is
Maxwell theory on a curved space-time.
But now,
it's the curved space-time metric that
we assume is fixed for the time being.
Fixed
for
the time
being.
So, assume the space-time with all its
little cones and all of that is already
given, okay?
Yes. Uh I'm not sure I understand the
question. What would be a non- classical
metric? What would be a classical
metric? What be would be a
non-classical? Yeah, well, non-classical
you wouldn't um you could still write
down these uh
these actions, but that uh
the Euler-Lagrange equations of it
wouldn't tell you what's going on. You
would have to do some quantum field
theory with that.
That's what I mean. So, classical refers
not to non-relativistic, it refers to
non-quantum.
And in fact, as you know, not in this
form, but Maxwell theory was written
down before the advent of relativity.
But it carries in it the relativity,
okay?
So now, um the Euler-Lagrange equations
for this
equations for fields
works as follows.
You got to be very careful.
Now, including
including this guy, all of this is the
um
the Lagrangian density L.
Why density? Well, because this is a
density. This is a space-time scalar
because everything is contracted, but
this makes it a Lagrangian density. And
it's important that you carry this with
you.
So, the equations of motion are DL by
Okay, so you start with deriving with
respect to the M's component. So, we
always do this in a chart, okay? Always
do it in a chart. Then comes the minus
DL. Now, you go with respect to the
derivatives of that, del S
AM, and then you derive with respect to
XS.
Now, this is for Lagrange, so 0 equals.
So, this is for Lagrangians that depend
on the A. By the way, where's the A? I
write here an A and here I write an F.
Well, this F is nothing but a short form
for, very important, del A AB
antisymmetrized * 2.
Right? And you know you might wonder how
you can act with a partial derivative on
the A. Well, you know that you can act
with a covariant derivative on it, and
then you antisymmetrize, and you know
that's the same. That you checked in the
tutorials that the gammas drop out.
Okay? So, it's this thing. The F is just
a short notation. The real degree of
freedom of electrodynamics is not the E
and the B field, it's the underlying
potential. You must vary with respect to
the potential.
So, in here, that's just the E's and the
B's actually this this action here, this
is E squared minus B squared, this part.
If you varied with respect to E and B,
the answer would be E equals 0, B equals
0, right? That can't be it. Um the
degrees of freedom with respect to to
which you have to vary is the potential.
Now, this These are the Euler-Lagrange
equations if the action depends on the A
and possibly up to the first derivative
of the A, which is the case here.
If you have an action that depends on
even more derivatives, this continues
with alternating sign, plus minus plus.
Now, you get the double derivative D by
DXS D by DX
XT, right? D2L
by D DTD
SAM, and so on.
Okay? And of course, at some point, when
the Lagrangian no longer depends on the
the Lagrangian density, you can stop
there.
Okay, these are the Euler-Lagrange
equations
for fields.
And um in the concrete example, I'm not
going to
carry that out, it's a little bit
stressful. Uh after some calculation,
you come to nabla M or nabla D by DXM,
to be precise, um
F
M
A equals 0.
So, these are the
um
inhomogeneous Maxwell equations.
Now, you wonder why inhomogeneous?
Isn't that homogeneous? Well, but you
could have the current J here.
But you would also only have that
current J here if this was coupled to a
current.
So, if you had plus
A acting on the current
* Q.
Or if it's a charge current, you don't
need the Q. It's essentially what we
wrote down before.
It's essentially what we wrote down
before. This makes the coupling to a
current.
Okay?
And the current itself,
for instance, if it comes from a point
particle, could be exactly this.
That's it. Yes? Is partial the
definition of FAB?
That's right. That's right. I was a
little bit sloppy with notation here. D
by DXA like this, and here we declared
the notation.
Okay.
So, all of this fits nicely. The
question is
if this these are the Euler-Lagrange
equations, where the inhomogeneous
Maxwell equations?
Who knows?
Yes? Is there
D
exterior derivative of this thing is
zero? Yes. So, essentially,
the idea that um
that you have the F given by this
immediately implies
uh that the um
del A FBC totally antisymmetrized, and
you checked as well
that this thing is the same as
this thing. Do you remember on the
problem sheet?
That this is zero, and these are the
homogeneous Maxwell equations.
Now again, if you want to compare with
the Maxwell equations as they appear in
Jackson on the first few pages, you go
to a frame to an observer frame, you
extract in terms of E's and B's, and
you'll get it.
Okay? In flat space-time.
In curved space-time, you get something
maybe corrected.
Okay. So, that's um
Maxwell theory, uh and that's
already the prototypical example. And
really, as I said, in classical physics,
it's the only example of a field theory
that's realized in nature.
Right? So, you have um
uh other well-liked examples.
Other example
well-liked
by textbooks
um is L Klein-Gordon.
There you say that's just a scalar
field, so that's uh
zero zero tensor field.
So, why was that?
Oh, I this already L, I want to write
down the S of Klein-Gordon
uh over the whole manifold and the same
assumption that this exists like that,
square root of minus G, and there you
have uh GAB del A phi, you know that
suffices on a scalar, del B phi.
And then you can have all possible kinds
of
extra terms like, for instance, this
one.
Like, for instance, this one, okay?
Where you say it's a Klein-Gordon field
of mass M. However, don't take it too
seriously. I mean, the question is what
does that mean? Actually, this mass can
only get a meaning then in quantum
theory again.
It's a scalar field, right? Um well, in
quantum theory, it could be a Higgs
field or something like this. Um but in
classical physics, we just don't have a
fundamental scalar field, we don't see
it.
Okay?
So, this is actually the the prime
example.
Now, why am I talking about matter in
the first place?
Well, I already told you, the Einstein
equations
have matter sources, so the curvature of
space-time will
be determined
parts of the curvature of space-time
will be determined by the matter
contents of the space-time.
Um
So, therefore, we need to talk about
matter.
So, third is the energy momentum tensor
of matter fields.
Now, I will give you a definition of the
energy momentum tensor that will not fit
the definition that you met in probably
field theory classes if you saw this.
Um
but it can be shown to coincide.
But, that's not easy and that has only
more or less recently been further
clarified. So, it's been an issue of
long debate, but anyway, I'm not going
to in that.
Um the prelude to this is that
at some point
we want
to write down
an action
for
the metric tensor itself. For the metric
tensor field
itself.
Because so far, we all always said,
"Let's assume there's a smooth manifold
and it's equipped with some Lorentzian
metric in a time orientation." And the
question is, "Which Lorentzian metric
should I choose?"
And the answer is, "We will write down
dynamical equations
for the metric that need to be solved
and the solutions are the metric you
should use."
And the equations will be the Einstein
equations. Okay? And in order to obtain
them, we will write down an action for
the metric tensor field itself.
But, then
so, um this
action
which we may call S grav, like gravity
action, that the
that takes the metric
will
be added
to
uh any
S matter
of whatever matter fields this depends
on an A, maybe a phi if you're
courageous and so on,
will be added to any S matter
in order to describe the total system.
So, we will have an S
total
that
contains, say, the metric and the
Maxwell field
and that will be the gravitational
action
that gives you dynamics to the G and
we'll need to specify this.
And there will be the S matter, for
instance, S Maxwell
that has the A and with the semicolon
it has also the G because the G
also appears in here. You remember? It
pulls the indices on the F.
Now, before we put the semicolon because
we said we only want to vary this action
with respect to A because we consider
the G as given. You remember?
But, now if we have an action for G, we
need to vary the total action with
respect to G. So, the semicolon becomes
a comma, meaning also the G can now be
varied. We can vary with respect to the
G. And we must, okay? So, if we have
something like this, we can
vary with respect to the A and then this
will not be seen and you just get
Maxwell's equations. Okay?
So, this is an example.
But, if you vary with respect to the G,
you will get a contribution from this
part and you will get a contribution
from that part, right?
And the contribution from this first
part will be called GAB. The variation
with respect to G from here will carry
two indices because the G carries two
indices.
And I will carry two indices down if I
vary with respect to the G down. We'll
do this in detail.
That will be the contribution from there
and there will be a contribution from
here if you vary with respect to G
because the G is in there.
So, the contribution from there will be
called minus TAB.
And I will fix some factors here such
that the contribution will finally be
called
minus two TAB and that contribution will
be called 1/16
pi G and G is the Newton constant,
Newton gravitational constant.
So, this is for those who want to get
the factors right.
That's the contribution from here,
that's the contribution from there and
the whole thing ought to be zero.
Now, this will be a general feature that
this action here
we will not change because this is just
what it is. So, we'll always get this
term.
Okay?
And we will, however, consider
situations where different matter is
present.
Now, it could be that you have a matter
action that doesn't depend on the G.
Those are so-called topological field
theories. They do not depend on the G.
They're rather exotic. They're very
interesting from theoretical points of
view,
but in nature, again, if we talk about
classical matter, this is anyway the
only classical field matter we have
and it comes with the G. But, also you
saw the Klein-Gordon field
takes the G. It requires the G here.
Okay? So, all the matter we actually
know in the standard model, for
instance, if you want to consider all
standard model matter also classically,
if you're so adventurous,
they all depend always of the G. So, you
very often, you actually all the time
you have the situation this term stays
fixed and you consider various matter
actions. Well, it's very convenient once
and for all to associate a matter action
to this object here, which you just get
by varying this guy with respect to G.
Okay? And then you always get the same
type of equation, namely
GAB
equals 8 pi G. It's the Newton constant,
G Newton I should write, G Newton
TAB. You always get the same type of
equation, which is called the Einstein
equation.
We still have to I still have to tell
you how this thing looks like because I
still have to tell you how this thing
looks like, but the idea is whatever
matter we have, the variation of it with
respect to the G is this object.
That's the secret why we're interested
in this object.
And that object has a name. Definition.
If S
for any matter field, I write a capital
phi, could be anything, G
matter
is a matter action,
the so-called
energy momentum tensor
is
T
AB
defined as
two, that's by convention, that's this
two,
um by you take out the density be- I
have a question about the two.
Yes.
Because of the two you would get
the two from
on the Einstein equation. So, it's
Yeah, that's true. That's true. That's
true. So, it's uh
it's 1/2 here. Okay, it's there.
And then I put the two here, but that's
of course a 1/2 in front. Sorry.
Okay?
It's this guy.
It's just convention in order to make it
coincide with the standard energy
momentum tensor.
Two by this. Well, I need you need to
vary with with the action you vary with
respect to the metric, but we know how
that works. I don't need to go through
variational calculus. I know that I just
start with L matter
with respect to GAB
minus
L matter
with respect to del del S GAB and this
is again a d by dxS. I'm now really
using this short form here.
The S
plus this higher derivatives and so on.
Okay?
And if I do the variation always with
this sign here,
I guess I need the minus here.
Okay.
So, sign conventions are notoriously
dangerous in this context because the L
matter contains the G
uh for instance, here. So, also the sign
of the G goes in because what you want
at the end, so uh this morning somebody
gave me the hint that this should be
called a Schrödinger minus.
It's only after at the end of the
calculation you measure and then you see
whether it's plus or minus. Okay? So, um
uh what you want. So, choose
all sign conventions.
This is the last one such that the T,
which is here
defined as a 2 0 tensor, but you could
also define it as a Well, anyway,
that epsilon 0 epsilon 0 is greater than
0. So, if this is uh
this eats two covectors, so it could eat
the epsilon 0 epsilon 0 covector
associated with an observer frame.
Observer frame is E, but epsilon is the
unique dual frame. You take the zeroth
one and you always want this to be
bigger than 0.
Okay? This is positive energy.
Okay? So, you always want it like that.
So, so be be careful here.
Okay?
So, um this is the energy momentum
tensor
of that matter action.
Because that's the variation already
expressed in terms of the Lagrangian
density.
Okay? And again, its role is that it
appears on the right-hand side of the
Einstein equations.
Right? So, example,
for Maxwell, for S Maxwell,
uh T
AB down and I'll pull the indices down
with the metric
is
uh FAM
F
BN Oh, god. I hope that the signs are
right. Uh minus 1/4 FMN
FMN up if you contract with the metric,
blah blah blah, uh GAB.
Or something of the type. I'm sorry. Um
I think it's right. Um
Okay, you you you calculate it, right? I
mean, see if I just exchange two indices
here, it's already a different sign and
so on. Well, calculate it. Okay.
Homework, check all signs
in today's lecture.
So, this is the energy momentum tensor
for Maxwell theory.
And will depend from point to point
depending on how the electric and the
magnetic field are. And then you have uh
observer-dependent quantities like T E0
E0 will be E squared plus B squared
if you think in these fields, and that's
the energy density. And um or you think
of um
T of E0 E alpha,
uh that's uh I think something E cross
B.
If you pull the index, that's the
momentum density.
Okay? So, you can extract these
quantities from the energy
momentum tensor.
Why do we choose the only positive and
negative solution?
Pardon me? Klein-Gordon, why do we
choose only the positive and negative
solution? If we have Klein-Gordon
equation, Yes. we often choose the
negative ones and
interpret them somehow.
Somehow? Um
Well, I mean, if I have negative energy
uh
in the matter, then
uh the system is unstable cuz the
matter can suck up more and more and
more energy.
And the system is unstable. So, that's
why you why you don't want that, right?
negative energies Yes. So, so there are
there a whole number of conditions you
could impose on an energy momentum
tensor.
So, the thing is the following. Because
we have only one type of matter
classically there,
um what one tries to do is one tries to
capture or to imagine what any future
matter one might discover, what kind of
energy momentum tensor it might have.
Not in detail, but from its properties.
So, there is a whole list of different
so-called energy conditions one can put
on this guy. Strong energy condition,
the dominant energy condition, dot dot
dot dot. Okay? They're all
made in order to somehow capture our
idea of matter.
But with just one example in the
classical domain, it's a rather academic
idea to get given abstract rule for
which you have only one example to test
it. Okay? So, um and that should capture
all the the future matter. But for
instance, in cosmology, so fact,
one often
um
does not specify
the fundamental equations of motion or
the fundamental action
for some
matter,
but is rather one is rather satisfied
to
assume
certain
properties
or forms
of
the energy momentum tensor TAB.
And the prime example we're also going
to look at is in cosmology
in a
homogeneous and isotropic universe.
We'll talk more about this. These are
symmetry conditions.
There are six killing vector fields
eliminating the metric.
In cosmology, one often considers a
perfect fluid.
The idea is that at large scales, the
galaxies or the galaxy clusters or what
not in the universe, they form a perfect
fluid that just flows.
And if it flows, it has a tangent vector
field, four tangent vector field U.
And then a perfect fluid
of pressure P
and density
rho
is modeled
by an energy momentum tensor TAB,
which is rho plus P U A U B. So, you use
the uh
components of the flow vector field.
Minus in our conventions, minus is
correct. Minus P
GAB.
Density rho,
pressure P, pressure P.
You see, I don't care what the fluid
consists of. It's a fluid with a certain
pressure and a certain density. And
there are of course arguments why it
should take this form.
That's not wrong. I mean, this is a
perfect fluid. That's what we call a
perfect fluid.
Um but you see, one doesn't care about
saying from what action does it come.
Okay, I think it's in fact rather
difficult to get this from an action.
This is phenomenology. You say we just
fill space-time with matter that has
this property because that's our idea of
how the contents of the universe at
very, very large scale looks like.
So, we
in in phenomenology, one plays these
games in order to make progress in
solving the Einstein's equations. You do
not always start with a fundamental
matter action and then go down. But what
you can do, for instance, you can ask
what is a radiation fluid?
What
is a fluid
of photons? Well, this is already a
quantum mechanical term, but you know
what I mean, of light particles, right?
What's the fluid of photons? Well, you
observe
that if you take the Maxwell energy
momentum tensor
I just wrote down before
and you contract its two indices, you
will get zero.
That was the reason for the 1/4 back
there because there was a metric with
another metric gives a dimension of
space-time, the fourth cancels, and so
on.
Um Well, it wasn't the reason for that.
That That came out because the action is
like that. But because of this 1/4, you
have this result. Now, you can say, I
mean, this is a very quick argument. Uh
uh one can make this more precise. You
can say, "Aha. So, if I now have a
fluid, perfect fluid AB, it should be a
perfect fluid of such stuff that I know
fundamentally, then please the perfect
fluid that is a radiation fluid
should satisfy the same." So, I apply
this to over there. So, I get rho plus P
U A U B G A B minus
P G A B G A B, right?
And uh I should have said here that
these Us, you see,
these Us
are
normalized.
And what do you get? They're normalized.
This is one.
Uh this is four.
So, you get rho plus P minus 4 P
is zero.
That is rho equals 3 P. That's wrong.
Oh, no, it's right. Correct. So, P is a
third rho.
And that's the um equation of state, as
one calls it.
Equation of state
for a radiation
fluid.
So, you see, I had here the P and the Q,
but I need to somehow relate them.
And that I must submit by hand. I have
to say what kind of fluid is this. I
could also set P to zero, then I have
dust. Just has a density, but no matter
how dense it becomes, it doesn't develop
pressure.
So, the late universe where everything's
very far away from each other,
there's no interaction. It's like dust.
The early universe where there's
radiation,
that's radiation dominated, we'll come
to that,
uh the pressure is the higher the higher
the density is.
Okay? So, you can play these games with
the energy momentum tensor, ignoring
what particular solution you choose
here.
So, I hope that this afternoon at 3:00,
if you don't mind, because I need to
rest my voice, otherwise I hope it will
fail.
At 3:00, we could reconvene. Is that
okay with the organization?
Yes. Okay. So, let's try to reconvene at
3:00. In case my voice does not recover,
uh we'll have an emergency plan.
Thank you.